Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new henry cavill
superman video
as you can see keeping himself very busy
building new superhero gaming pcs
there's a bunch of funny stories that
henry cavill tells about being a
hardcore gamer he is very open about
being a hardcore
nerd there's also some dc movie news and
justice league stuff that's going on
that i'll add to the end of the video
too
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we'll do a new amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know where
you want superman's first cameo to be in
the new dc movies
i'll just number these as we go along
just to stay organized but if you guys
couldn't tell
first cool easter egg the blue tank top
that he's wearing there while he's
building this
is actually the exact same one that he
was wearing during the justice league
snyder cut livestream he did with zack
snyder back in may
when they announced that they were doing
the snyder cut so i'm assuming that this
video is actually pretty old and he's
just posting it right now he just posted
it to his social like hey this is what i
was doing during the quarantine
playing a ton of video games zack snyder
was doing that big live stream rewatch
of the man of steel movie doing a live
commentary with a bunch of cool behind
the scenes easter eggs and details
and at the end of it henry cavill popped
in in his blue tank top to do a giant
zoom call in the formal announcement
that they were doing the justice league
snyder cut like hey
i think you should totally release it
and then boom they're releasing it
then people took all these screen caps
of henry cavill in this video and turned
it into a bunch of gaming memes
like henry cavill with all his facial
hair in the tank top doing minecraft
let's plays
way back when they streamed this i joked
that this should be one of the next
superman cameos in the flash flashpoint
movie like ezra miller's flash has that
giant video wall with all the screens in
the background
they should just insert some of these
henry cavill gaming memes in the
background on one of the screens
and not call any attention to it or ever
mention it during the movie
for those of you wondering what he's
gaming on here this is obviously an amd
system
i don't think he's doing any kind of
integration or anything like that
usually pc builders like this don't pay
big time money for people like henry
cavill to do ads for them
usually you just see other tech
youtubers doing stuff like this
but for those of you wondering what
other kinds of gaming he does for the
most part he said that he is firmly team
pc master race there was a big witcher
netflix interview that he did last year
where he disses the hell out of consoles
in favor of playing games on pcs
so i'm assuming he's not going to be a
big ps5 or xbox series x fan
playstation or xbox pc oh wow yeah
you're a pc gamer yeah
was that from when you were young or yes
yeah my dad got me into that when i was
um
very very young did you kind of build
your own gaming pc um i
have not quite ventured into building my
own myself i've definitely
have i have had custom pcs over the
years um
that will be the next the next project
as soon as i find enough time
you could tell this interview was
happening last year because he said i
haven't built my own custom pc
i'm just waiting to have the time for
that to be my next project
turns out he found himself with a ton of
extra time during the quarantine
i think when he was doing that interview
though talking about how pcs were so
much better than consoles he was
mostly also talking about the witcher 3
but my favorite henry cavill gaming
story is actually a superman man of
steel story that goes way back
so back when zack snyder first decided
to cast henry cavill around 2011
this is actually him wearing christopher
reeve's superman costume by the way
way way back before man of steel zack
snyder
called henry cavill himself to tell him
he was going to become the next superman
it's a huge deal to play such an iconic
character so of course zack snyder
wanted to call him himself and tell him
the good news
but the way henry cavill tells the story
he missed zack snyder's call
saying that he got the part because he
was too busy playing world of warcraft
he wasn't addicted to gaming or anything
like that it wasn't like a huge legit
problem
it was just a coincidence that he missed
the call but after he finished playing
that day he saw the missed call
had a major heart attack and then
started calling his agent and calling
zack snyder back to thank him profusely
well the first time i got the call i
actually missed it
i was i was playing world warcraft at
the time
and i had my priorities straight
wait a minute you were at home it's not
like you weren't home you were home but
you were playing
world of warcraft and the phone rings
and you're like i'll get that later
i'll get yeah yeah absolutely i'll get
that later and i was playing uh
it was an important part of a particular
dungeon that i was going through
and and it's cool now that i'm superman
yeah henry cavill hasn't really stopped
playing video games or anything like
that
he mostly just does his hardcore gaming
when he's in between movies or filming
the witcher
2020 has just been a really weird case
where everyone in hollywood was just
stuck waiting doing nothing for several
months before they could go back to
filming new movies and tv shows
thus the quarantine superman gaming pc
so henry cavill
playing a ton of video games while he's
busy also trying to convince warner
brothers to do another superman man of
steel movie
so we'll probably get more news about
that at the dc fandom comic-con event in
august
zack snyder is also going going to be
dropping the justice league snyder cut
trailer during that two the big proper
trailer
they're doing panels for all the big dc
movies all the big tv shows and even
some of the hbo
tv shows they're working on the big
budget ones like they just announced the
batman
hbo tv series they have the green
lantern hbo tv series
whatever big trailers they drop of
course i'll do a video for it i'm sure
marvel will do the same thing later
there's a big comic con at home event
happening next week too so i'll do any
big trailer videos that drop during that
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them
in terms of other big superman movies
they actually just released a new dc
animated
superman man of tomorrow movie but it's
a completely new animation style from
the previous dc animated universe the
other big news you probably just saw is
they announced more characters from the
justice society
for the black adam movie so i'll
probably do a video for that later today
that video should post later tonight if
i can finish it fast enough
everyone click here for the new justice
league snyder cut trailer
and click here for that new netflix
umbrella academy season 2 trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!